thank you I'm sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you I'm sorry I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report it's October 19th
2022. we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and Blaze TV subscribe over at
Rumble if you have not you never know
when they're going to pull the plug on
YouTube and uh before we get to it today
and I promise you people we have a big
show it is information packed and uh
you're gonna dig it but before we get to
it I have to address something that I
said yesterday and uh they're going
after me you know the media people
they're going after me mediaite which is
a site that watches people in the media
and if you say anything off color if you
make a joke if you just do anything that
falls outside Democrat Orthodoxy they're
gonna get you and well put up the Tweet
they got me yesterday Dave Rubin crudely
bashes Stacy Abrams only thing on her
resume is record at eating at the Golden
Corral buffet it did get a whopping 13
uh likes but that is true I did say that
about her yesterday it was said in jest
and back in the day and I'm a gen xer
I'm a child of the 80s and the 90s we
were allowed to make jokes about people
this was a popular way of communicating
often comedians would stand in front of
groups of people on a stage with a
microphone and say funny things and
people would laugh F uh but this did
make me think maybe I'm being a little
overboard because people larger people
who go to buffets have been ridiculed
for a long time and and bad things often
happen to them you may remember what
happened to uh John Pinette
[Applause]
oh he'd come out every hour
son of a [ __ ] still here
[Applause]
look he go again
this is some of our best work and we're
only two minutes into the show guys I'm
feeling good uh yes so look people have
been making fun of larger people at
buffets for a long time be it a Golden
Corral or your local Chinese buffet or
whatever it might be in your town
whatever Buffet it is a sushi buffet any
any sort of buffet but really am I the
evil person here for making a silly joke
about her not having anything on her
resume which by the way is true there is
nothing that she's ever really
accomplished that would warrant her
being governor of Georgia uh here she is
what this is about six seven months ago
I I tweeted this one out when people
were going after me here she is now
she's a larger woman and we're told that
you know the size of your body oh being
overweight is a co-morbidity related to
Kobe that was a big thing she had no
problem sitting there with her [ __ ]
eating Grin While a bunch of kids who
were at no risk of covet and again this
is not even this isn't two years ago
this is like six eight months ago so
like that and look at her sitting there
with no mask after after she gave a
speech to them with no mask while these
kids while the teachers and the parents
and the administrators and this woman
abuse these children who will likely
have speech defects and delayed speech
and all sorts of social conditioning
problems and everything else but I know
I'm the bad guy because I made a joke
about a buffet and of course it's not
like this is a woman who would deny
elections right because she wouldn't do
that sort of thing that would be over
the top I do have one very affirmative
statement to make
we won but I didn't lose I got the votes
but we won't know exactly how many
because of how they cheated I did win my
election I just didn't get to have the
job we were robbed of an election using
the word rigged using the word steel do
you think it's dangerous going into
2020. I don't because we could actually
back it up
to what I believe
was a stolen election I'm not saying
they stole it for me
I'm really realizing guys we should have
two shows going here we should
revolutionize the online video show we
should have a show that we're doing
normally like this and then also a show
where there's a camera just doing us
while we're talking as the clips are
playing because here is now a picture
okay so Dave you're you're still being
rude yes she's a large woman let's not
make fun of people at the buffet it's
too much it's too much and sure she
denied the election but that can't be
the only thing on her resume well it's
true actually we want to give credit
where credit is due uh here is an image
of Stacy Abrams in a Star Trek episode
from about six or eight months ago where
she played President of the United Earth
fiction
fiction has been destroyed by reality
it's very very sad anyway I'm sure
they'll go after me today because I
doubled down on these Buffet jokes and
by the way rest in peace John Pinette
who was a great comedian that was the
comedian I just showed you there you've
been here for hours it's just great
stuff uh he also John Pinette you might
recognize him even if you're not a huge
standup guy he was the he played the
large guy in the season series finale
the two-part series finale of Seinfeld
where they're in this town I think it
was in Massachusetts right Latham
Massachusetts if we're not mistaken they
see him being mugged and they're all
making jokes about him instead of
helping him and that leads to the trial
and yada yada okay let's get to the show
today the theme is that basically if
you're a Democrat these days knowing
that the wheels are coming off this
thing the ends justify the means they're
losing Steam on all fronts and there's a
desperation there is a Mania related to
these people that they've got to ramp up
because because now we're two weeks out
from an election that does not look good
for them and as always
the president's incumbent party pretty
much always gets mauled in the midterms
however this one looks like a mall of
palooza okay it is going to be a mess
and they're ramping up the crazy and uh
we're gonna unpack some of the crazy
before we do that let me talk to you
guys about Rex MD uh you know that most
guys hate going to the doctor it
literally takes half a day just to get
it done and you don't want your to talk
to your doctor about certain issues
here's the thing most men's health
issues have really Simple Solutions Rex
MD is all about Simple Solutions Rex MD
makes getting generic and branded Viagra
and Cialis easy everything's online even
the prescription and they deliver to
your door no office visits no talking to
a receptionist super simple did you know
that Viagra can cost around 90 bucks a
pill but Rex MD has generic Viagra for
as low as two dollars a pill just fill
out quick medical questionnaire quick
medical questionnaire on their website a
doctor will review your situation and
prescribe you generic Viagra if
appropriate your medication gets shipped
to your door right away with two free
two-day shipping it's fast simple and
cheap and you can access your us license
Rex MD physician anytime you need
afterwards Rex MD has helped over 300
000 guys get generic Viagra quickly and
conveniently Rex MD works and it works
the very first night starter packs of
generic Viagra or Cialis are now
available for our viewers but you've got
to go to rexmd.com Ruben to get started
that's rexmd.com Reuben go direct70.com
Reuben today to get a starter pack
prescription of generic Viagra or Cialis
all orders come with free two-day
shipping Rex MD The Authority in men's
Telehealth okay so as the crazy gets
ramped up one thing I am definitely
making note of is that the people who
have lied all along and the people who
locked you in your house and didn't let
you go to work and didn't let you go to
the gym and demanded you be injected
with things well they're coming back and
they're trying to scare you about a
whole bunch of other stuff and one of
the Prime purveyors of this is Bill
Gates now Bill Gates created Microsoft
in the 80s and Microsoft Windows
obviously was the operating system on
PCS and you had Microsoft Paint remember
Microsoft Paint what else did people do
on that thing on Windows I guess you had
to you had Excel it was mostly paint
you'd click a color you could fill you
could do all sorts of stuff anyway he
creates this thing and he becomes a
billionaire okay fine he's done some
other things over the years but somehow
he isn't now involved in fixing the
climate somehow he is now now involved
in vaccinating you uh he also is now the
largest Farmland owner in the United
States there is something very strange
around Bill Gates and he was interviewed
just a day or two ago talking about the
European energy crisis and uh why it's
actually good you know people did get a
little optimistic about how quickly the
transition could be done now without uh
the Russian natural gas being available
in Europe
uh you know we're it's a setback you
know we need to find non-russian
hydrocarbon sources to substitute for
those so there's cold plants running and
a variety of things uh because you know
keeping
you know people warm uh keeping those
economies in decent shape uh is a
priority now on the other hand it's good
for the long run because uh people won't
want to be dependent on Russian natural
gas so they'll move to these new
approaches more rapidly he's evil it's
just so obvious that he he is an evil
dude trying to control the world like he
got drunk on the money and the power and
somehow he has put his gross pudgy
tentacles into everything he sort of
digs the fact that the winters come in
and you know somehow Nordstrom pipeline
blew up very bizarre we still can't
figure out who blew it up did Russia
blow up their own pipeline to Germany
and are the Germans going to freeze now
but doesn't really worry he's not really
concerned about that because this is
kind of good this is kind of good
because then we can kind of move into
the energy sector that green energy
thing that I want to do with AOC because
she's a real wizard so this is kind of
good everything that they do the ends
justify the means we will blow up
pipelines perhaps or we just won't even
know who blew up the pipeline it's funny
that a lot of things happen these days
where bad things happen we never find
out who did it you know we get all this
misinformation from the uh the
pharmaceutical companies about covet we
never really figure out who who said
what no one ever pays the price for it
right fauci's still making the rounds
all that sort of stuff pipelines blow up
we never really find out who did it you
know the the Supreme Court leak about
the abortion case uh that gets leaked we
stopped asking questions about that uh
it's very weird but Bill Gates seems to
be involved in everything now you might
be concerned that Bill Gates who again
is Not Elected he is not in charge of
any government as far as I know you
might be concerned that he is so
involved into the in the day-to-day
operations of again what you get
injected with how you get gas and energy
because ultimately this will come to the
United States even though he's talking
about Europe now and you might be
concerned about all that because he was
wrong and or lied about covid the entire
time as well as doing it right alongside
most of his buddies 10 and That vaccine
uh key goal is to stop the transmission
to get the immunity levels up so that
you get almost no almost no uh infection
going on whatsoever everyone who takes
the vaccine is not just protecting
themselves but reducing their
transmission uh to other people and
allowing Society to get back to normal
stop
s every vaccinated person a vaccinated
person gets exposed to the virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else it cannot use a vaccinated
person as a host to go get more people
that means the vaccines will get us to
the end of this essentially vaccines
block you from getting and giving
um the virus fully vaccinated people
are at a very very low risk of getting
covet 19.
therefore if you've been fully
vaccinated you no longer need to wear a
mask when people are vaccinated they can
feel safe that they are not going to get
infected we have all the vaccines we
need we just need our people to take it
a for their own protection for the
protection of their family but also to
break the chain of transmission it is
now obvious obvious that these were all
lies many of us kind of thought they
were lying all along many of us stuck to
our wits and did not get the vaccine if
we were otherwise healthy and take care
of ourselves and eat right and get a
little sunshine and took whatever uh
accommodations into account related to
our lives we're all individuals and the
super fit 35 year old guy who goes to
the gym every day and eats Ryan and does
all that isn't say as susceptible as
maybe Stacy Abrams not to be a dick
that's just true right that's just true
now the reason I keep showing you these
videos is I want this to be lodged in
your freaking brain like a giant nail
that someone has hammered in so that as
they continue to lie to you as Bill
Gates comes and says Ah we have to do
this related to energy or maybe you'll
just stay in your house and eat bug
slime all day while I have all of the
Farmland is he buying all the Farmland I
mean is this is this all crazy
conspiracy stuff or is it stuff that's
right in front of our freaking faces is
I just want you to know that they lied
to you all along and they're just gonna
they're gonna do it again that is that
is the beauty of their evil parasite
they do it you see it and then somehow
you get tricked again but not you I'm
not talking about you you I'm talking
about you the collective you but you
guys watching this you get it uh but how
about a little bit more of these people
uh just lying about stuff
I wonder if you would recommend locking
down schools if you had to do it all
over again well you know again it's
first of all I didn't recommend locking
anything down
closing schools teleworking we need to
start thinking about that now should the
country shut down bars and restaurants
what the country should do is absolutely
and more so proportionately in those
areas that have Community spread don't
go to bars don't go to restaurants don't
go to places where there are crowds and
Gatherings the schools should be closed
my question for you is what was the most
crucial decision you had to make during
the pandemic I recommended to the
president that we shut the country down
lockdown has its consequences you use
lockdowns to get people vaccinated
if you could go back to March of 2020
and start over with the pandemic
response what would you do differently
we would do a lot differently and there
would have been much much more stringent
restrictions
have you no shame sir he should be
embarrassed to walk in public not only
is he just caught in lie after lie after
lie I mean how much more blatant you
wanted than that but his biggest regret
is that they didn't do more they didn't
lock you in your house faster they
didn't separate you from Grandma faster
they didn't let you go to a funeral of a
loved one even faster you vile reptilian
creature
oh terrible but speaking of terrible
people let's not forget that the entire
machine did this right so this wasn't
just the expert class of Bill Gates and
Anthony fauci that did this the entire
corporate machine tried to scare the
hell out of you and make you hate people
that's what they tried to do more than
anything else this clip was going viral
yesterday here's a joke that Jimmy
Kimmel made about a year ago Jimmy
Kimmel and jokes two things that should
not be said in the same sentence Dr
fauci said that if hospitals get any
more overcrowded they're going to have
to make some very tough choices about
who gets an ICU but that choice doesn't
seem so tough to me vaccinated person
having a heart attack yes come right on
him we'll take care of you unvaccinated
guy who gobbled horses goo rest in peace
Wheezy you're
still gonna
want dimwits out there all right so just
on the base level it's just vile it's
just vile people made decisions for
themselves actually the people who
decided not to get vaxed I know many
many many many many many many many many
people who decided not to get backs and
none of them regretted they're feeling
pretty good these days because now it's
turning out that it did not work and
people are having all sorts of side
effects and and just the idea that the
government was forcing you to do this
and everything else it's also
interesting there that the the 35
writers or however many writers he have
that the joke that they came up with was
oh vaccinated person having a heart
attack yeah that is one of the side
effects and Florida just did a study and
males 18 to 35 are having something like
an 84 percent increase in heart related
issues uh so uh that's kind of that's
that's a tough one there Jimmy but just
the vileness of it the vileness of of no
we are not going to take care of a
certain amount of people right that you
would make a joke that would imply that
doctors should be making decisions based
on things of that nature it's just it's
absolutely disgusting but speaking of
disgusting uh let's go to the state that
Jimmy Kimmel does his show from of
course I'm talking about California Los
Angeles specifically uh Tucker Carlson
last night uh did a segment on how Gavin
Newsom the most evil when I speak of
evil reptilian lizard people only
Trudeau is even close uh well Gavin
Newsom is basically trying to make it a
crime to criticize Pfizer in California
yes really we've got video going away
now politicians in California were just
caught colluding with Twitter to censor
political critics
but instead of stopping the illegal
unconstitutional totally immoral
censorship Governor Gavin Newsom decided
to build it will punish doctors for the
crime of disagreeing with Gavin Newsom
right because remember so it's between
you and your doctor but now Gavin Newsom
who's not a doctor there's like a [ __ ]
is somehow telling your doctor what to
think yeah
under this new law doctors can no longer
spread quote false or misleading
information regarding the nature and
risks of the virus that would be
coronavirus it's prevention and
treatment and the development safety and
effectiveness of covid-19 vaccines
then what you're not allowed to
criticize Pfizer it's now a crime in
California oh shareholders of Pfizer
anyone probably
okay so this is really extraordinary
stuff and this is a massive massive
escalation on the assault on Free Speech
which is just endlessly happening to us
virtually every day uh the idea that the
government of California would tell
doctors uh that they cannot you know
spread this misinformation well it's
like well how about all the doctors that
for two years said the vaccine worked
and said that there were no side effects
and said that everybody needed it and
all of the stuff uh would those people
be punished and then you see how the
collusion with big Tech works and how
the government is actually at some level
now violating our first amendment rights
California passes a law saying oh you
the doctor can't spread misinformation
well now if the doctor shares his
thoughts on Twitter and then evil Gavin
Newsom or Joe Biden or anyone from an
Administration calls up Twitter and
Twitter takes information down that is a
violation of the first amendment of your
right to free speech but that is what is
happening in blue States what happens in
Cali Expo reports to other blue States
and as a Floridian I'd like to say good
luck with all of that
but let's Circle back to Bill Gates this
European energy crisis and what he's
saying about all of that because
obviously this is all rate related to
this war not war this war that we're
sort of in we're paying for and we're
shipping weapons over uh where Russia
has invaded Ukraine and again as I
always say you can't just invade a
Sovereign Nation and every nation has a
right to defend itself but at this point
considering we're giving them millions
of dollars we're not even checking if
they're spending that money with in an
equitable fashion for God's sakes
um you know should we uh have a better
sense of what what's happening with that
money and uh do you think maybe some of
the rhetoric is a problem remember two
weeks ago uh when uh Joe Biden said that
nuclear Armageddon is uh is on the way
well uh Karen Jean-Pierre our black
lesbian press secretary got asked about
that again yesterday
why is it that the president was talking
about nuclear Armageddon behind closed
doors to political donors two weeks ago
rather than speaking directly with the
American people about that topic but
they always press your colleagues there
were a few of your colleagues that were
in the room well given the severity and
the significance of that threat isn't
that something that the President should
perhaps well we've talked about we
should should I mean but there was there
was again there was press in the room
it's not like he was he was not saying
it in secret he knew that the Press was
in the room at the time when he was
making the comments look the president
we've talked about this this is like two
weeks ago conversation guys guys
the nuclear Armageddon stuff that was
two weeks ago can we talk about you know
I don't know can we talk about drag
queen happy hour or no drag queen happy
hour that's a good one too drag queen
should be having happy hour instead of
uh whatever they're doing Library hour
with the kids it's two weeks ago the
Armageddon thing forget about that
well you know it seems like it's a bit
of a problem you know what I mean
because again that Putin guy he's got
the nukes and if you don't give him an
off-ramp guy with big weapons might use
big weapons instead of desperation but
what's happening right now is that it
seems like the Democrats and the
establishment the corporate press
whatever you want to call it they're
basically willing to do anything for
Ukraine whatever for Ukraine means uh
even basically getting us into a nuclear
war which is why
six months ago nobody was talking about
a nuclear war everyone was like ah no
we'll deal with this thing real quick in
and out no problem it's all good but
no now we're all kind of talking about
it well Jordan Peterson was on Piers
Morgan's show in the UK this is from
about eight or ten days ago uh and Piers
asked him how does this War end
how does this war end do you think
we're gonna find out this winter well I
I know what I would do in his shoes
I'd wait till the first cold snap and
shut off the tops right
he's got the control over there
of course he's going to do that he's
already warned the West with his
insistence that maintenance problems
were necessary and the pipelines do you
think he will use a nuclear weapon
if necessary he'll use a tactical
Battlefield weapon even if it starts
world war three it won't probably why
because we wouldn't respond
what's in it for us
if you let him do it and get away with
it where does that end then you are into
it well look there's a lot you can get
yourself in this situation no problem
where there's no good outcome we're
trying to do that right now on every
front we can possibly imagine we can
easily get ourselves in a situation
where it's hell this way and hell that
way that we're that's highly probable
the reason I wanted to show you that
clip I mean you guys know my feelings
about Jordan but it's so interesting how
there's so little honest political
analysis about what's going on in Russia
Ukraine in essence if you say anything
like ah I don't really want World War
III I am a little bit concerned that
we're poking the bear with this guy it
doesn't mean that what he did was right
or that Crimea should be taken back to
Russia or any of that stuff they
basically call you a Russian operative
this is exactly what Hillary Clinton did
to Tulsi gabbard when she wasn't taking
the the Democrat Party Line on Russia
from two years ago and on Syria Etc this
is what they do so there's very little
Divergence from mainstream opinion on
this which is that we should just keep
escalating I for one would prefer not to
be involved in World War III I've had a
nice run the last couple years things
are feeling good uh could we maybe not
do the dropping nukes all over the place
uh but Jordan calmly because he's not
Jordan's not a political analyst he's
not purely a political analyst what he's
talking about is human in Psychology the
human psychology that is driving Putin
that is driving all these International
actors some to escalate some to not
understand what they're escalating for
given more more weapons more weapons
keep defeating him that seems right but
you have to understand human psychology
of what happens to people when they're
on the verge of losing what happens to
that wounded dog in the corner in those
last moments you think it might lash out
so Jordan continued to lay out some of
the outcomes that could happen to all of
us if we keep escalating this thing
everybody I met in Keys the capital city
were utterly Resolute don't give them an
inch of our land yeah well I don't I
can't speak to that because I don't know
what the preconditions for peace might
be but I do know that naive Notions that
the Russians are going to lose somehow
or that we're going to win
I I don't I just don't understand I
don't understand that well what do you
mean we're going to win what are we
going to win here exactly well I guess a
victory would be that the Russians
retreated from Ukraine
with with Ukrainian ruins
right well that's a hell of a victory
like I think Putin could manage that
because I think he could tell his people
and I think they might buy it it's like
we accomplished our objective we
devastated Ukraine and we kept it out of
the hands of the West
we can't win against Vladimir Putin
anyways because
you cannot win against someone you
cannot say no to
period
and we can't say no to Putin because we
sold our soul for his oil and gas and we
did that to elevate our moral stature in
relationship to saving the planet and so
here we are yeah facing a very dire
winter
hoisted on the patard of our own
foolishness and moral presumption we're
saving the planet
we'll see I don't think so
you could trade every political analyst
on CNN MSNBC
etc etc for a little of that right there
what is he saying hey this is the guy
with the oil and gas this is the guy
with the nukes I don't like the guy but
we got a real problem on our hands if he
shuts all that stuff off and then we
don't give him some way of saying hey
this thing has to end well he could drop
a nuke and then as he said in the
previous clip it's like well what what
do we do then do we drop a nuke on them
and then they drop another nuke
elsewhere and then
this would be a problem but what's also
coming around on this related to the
election in about two weeks is that
Ukraine is simply not a winning issue
for Democrats I think most people feel
how I feel and how I felt from the
beginning which is why I haven't talked
about Ukraine a ton until they've now
escalated it into this nonsense I think
most Americans wisely are like you know
we got enough problems here you guys
have wrecked the economy you did all
this nonsense via covid we have huge
huge problems at home we have a
president who everyone knows is mentally
incapacitated like we got some [ __ ] we
got to sort out here and then we can
maybe help Ukraine also we're getting
tired of just funding everything all the
time knowing that we don't have money
etc etc but this ends justify the mean
strategy that the Democrats are pushing
are actually hurting the Democrats and
they're having trouble seeing it which
is a kind of beautiful thing because I
think it's leading their party to a path
of Destruction uh which is sort of
what's needed at this point another
example of that not only Ukraine is
January 6th they keep bringing up
January 6th and the Insurrection that
nobody brought any weapons to and nobody
had a long-term plan to take over the
government and it was done in a few
hours and there was a guy wearing a
funny helmet and Bouquet a bunch of
other weird things uh here's Nancy
Pelosi this is Incredible video so it
turns out that Nancy Pelosi was taping a
documentary on January 6th what are the
chances that she had cameras in her
office with her tape and documentary
here she is talking about how she was
going to punch Trump that day
[Applause]
I told him they don't have the resources
to protect him here
so at the moment he is not coming but
that could change
oh it comes I'm going to punch him out
I'm waiting for this for trespassing on
the capitol grounds I want to punch him
out and I'm going to go to jail I'm
going to be happy
yeah I mean okay Democrats you're
allowed to threaten violence and when
you do it I don't ask them you're going
to punch him out can you imagine Nancy
Pelosi punching anybody the only thing
she uses that arm for is to grab for the
vodka bottle all right uh what's
interesting about January 6th that of
course the uh the silly January 6
commission doesn't talk about a
mainstream media doesn't talk about is
that Donald Trump called for more
reinforcements at the Capitol uh we have
a tweet here from uh this is from Mark
this is well it's from Mark Meadows so
Mark Meadows the former white house
chief of staff told Fox News you're
looking at the memo obviously itself uh
told White House told Fox News is Sunday
morning Futures with Maria Bartiromo
that Trump issued a direct order to have
up to 10 000 troops Ready Cash Patel
suggested 20 000 troops so Trump upped
it to 20 000. he was turned down by
Bowser that's Muriel Bowser who's the DC
mayor and Nancy Pelosi do you get that
do you get that so Nancy's sitting there
acting all tough I'm gonna punch Trump
and did she seem like she was that the
Insurrection was about to come and get
her was she afraid of any of that of
course not but the fact is no one is
disputing this that on that day Trump
wanted 20
000 National Guard at the Capitol and
she said no is that not bizarre but here
she is this is just yesterday on the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC talking to Andrea Mitchell about
her punching comments I said I would
have punched him out I would have gone
to jail and I would have been happy to
do so would you have done for our
country
that he wouldn't have had the courage to
come to the hill he's all talk
now just remember if this was a
republican talking about punching a
Democrat we'd have a hearing there'd be
impeachment nine Republicans or even but
when Democrats want to punch people it's
okay because as you guys know the only
privilege in America is Democrat
privilege uh what's happening of course
to Nancy Pelosi is that she knows she's
about two weeks from losing her house
majority status and uh the evidence of
that is she doesn't believe in polls
anymore she always likes Bulls when
they're going to her Advantage she
doesn't like them anymore and she's
ignoring she doesn't accept that most
people actually don't necessarily care
about Ukraine that much they certainly
don't care about January 6th that much
but they do seem to care about crime and
inflation so let's talk about Rising
inflation concerns along with crime
giving momentum new momentum to
Republicans after the Democrats were
closing the Gap in the historic Gap yes
so
after the Supreme Court ruling there was
huge outrage that has seemed to subside
at least among overriding concerns first
of all let me say that I think that much
of what you've said I don't agree with
that is to say the New York Times poll I
think is an outlier poll you decide one
poll but all the others it's also the
real clear politics average is showing
similar issues no but they but that was
one that brought down the average and it
was an outlier it wasn't even that big a
sample so I I dismissed that oh Nancy
Nancy Nancy look I don't love polls
either and there are outlier polls and
all that but the simple truth is
everyone knows everyone knows ask
anybody ask yourself
stop this video right now pause it and
ask yourself while it's live but ask
yourself this question what am I not
happy with in America right now and the
two things on everyone's mind is
inflation I.E the economy and crime
those are the two big things and who's
dropping the ball on that whose cities
have the most crime whose cities have
the crazed unemployment and have all the
homelessness and the crime that comes
with it and all of that stuff and who is
in charge that is crushing the economy
leading to all of these problems it is
the Democrats so Nancy may not like
these polls but Nancy uh you in danger
girl as Whoopi Goldberg said in uh ghost
remember that Molly you in danger uh
here's Nancy Pelosi going all in on
Biden because she's in on it her and gay
Pete and then Kamala all they've got is
Biden got us here so we got to go down
with the [ __ ] but in some cases there's
no substitute for experience and I think
that what we had been through with the
legislation under the leadership of
President Biden who has done a
spectacular regular job he's had a
better two years than most presidents
that you can name certainly in the
recent Generations
like what planet is she on what planet
are you on Nancy Pelosi I'll have what
she's having because the woman is on
something special
it's absolutely insane he's spectacular
he's done a better job than most
presidents in recent memory what are you
talking about every metric look at the
stock market today look at your 401k
you wander around New York City see
what's going on it's a debacle this is
presidency is a debacle and a sham and
as Phoenix just said to me could you
just imagine if Biden ran again could
you just I mean imagine where Biden will
be at mentally and physically in two
years you know what I say do it I'm all
for it you know you guys want to keep
pretending this is real keep going go go
with the lie you don't have much else so
throw Biden out there again and uh how
about we throw up DeSantis and then
we'll see what happens when Ron DeSantis
and Joe Biden are on the debate stage
together like try to imagine that try to
imagine that it will be wild uh wild
here's some info from news Nation on
what's Happening actually in your
pocketbook President Biden took office
since then the average American family
has lost six thousand dollars in
purchasing power due to inflation
monthly savings have collapsed 83
percent the average 401K is down 34
000. not good those arrows down those
are problems that you have less spending
power your money is worth less while the
prices of things go up this is a problem
uh and that your 401k what most of us
put money into every year there's tax
benefits to it and also it helps you
retire so that you don't have to work
your entire life right so you can enjoy
the fruits of your labor in your later
years uh that is now down significantly
this is a problem but as I said they
have to keep going in with Biden because
there's nothing else there is literally
nothing else for these people uh Kamala
was asked if she's going to stick around
for uh Biden too we are at the midterm
election Point as we look ahead will we
see Biden Harris ticket for 2024
I am focused on the midterms which are
happening in a total of 26 days and I am
looking forward to that the president
has said he intends to run and if he
does I will be running with him
okay lady have at it have at it two
years from now Joe Biden is going to run
for president again because we're in
Idiocracy it ain't happening to people
it ain't happening they'll most likely
get rid of him before before that one
way or another but their strategy seems
to be this Pelosi strategy of going all
in and kamala's all in everybody's all
in and what can they do as they go all
in on stuff that people don't care about
while the stuff the people does care
about spin's out of control well they
could scare the bejesus out of you here
is California congressman and oh all
right oh it's the last five dollars I
have on my desk here so we're gonna have
to get some more cash uh here's
California Congressman Eric swalwell he
is a really really uh he's just an idiot
he he's an idiot he's a bad dude he's
one of these people that calls everyone
racist uh he also 100 for sure was
sleeping with a Chinese spy uh when I
had Kevin McCarthy the GOP leader on the
show he laid out all of the details you
can find the video maybe we'll play it
in the next day or two if something else
what pops up but so Eric swallow who has
slept with a Chinese spy a Chinese spy
who then helped staff his office and
then he got on intelligence committees I
mean it's crazy stuff he's one of the
absolute worst on the Democrat side he
put up this ad on abortion and it's it's
I'm actually sorry that I have to show
it to you but here we go
[Music]
you're weird he is weird but cute
Rose
Mary Anderson yes I have a warrant for
your arrest arrest for what penal code
243 violation unlawful termination of a
pregnancy you've got to be kidding me
that that is my personal business that's
for the courts to decide man your
medical records have been subpoenaed and
Dr Landry's already in custody
no
because you you can't just you will have
to submit to a physical examination
put your hands behind your back now why
is this happening
love you honey bear
we're just enforcing the law here
elections have consequences
vote Democrat on November 8th stop
Republicans from criminalizing abortion
everywhere
protect women's rights and freedom
please don't do this
Eric swalwell you are an extraordinary
piece of [ __ ] like what else how can I
analyze this in any more now mediate
gonna write a thing Dave Rubin called
swallow a piece of [ __ ] swallow by the
way who farted live on MSNBC remember
that one on Chris Matthews then they
pretended it was a coffee cup moving on
the desk
um you see what I'm saying about this
thing where all they have is fear that
that is a bad dystopian science fiction
movie he just made right there
um all they have is fear do you know
that virtually every single even the
most ex I don't like the word extreme
related to this but even the most
pro-life politicians in America uh have
certain caveats for abortion in the case
of rape or incest etc etc places like
Florida I keep saying this which is
thought of as now this radical
right-wing Freedom loving very scary
place has 15 weeks on abortion that is
the moderate position that Senator Rubio
who voted for it is he personally in his
life is pro-life life our governor Ron
DeSantis he personally is pro-life but
Florida as a red state has made a
compromise at 15 weeks 15 weeks again
which is three and a half months okay
we're well past heartbeat we're past
organs being developed and all of those
things and then you know they're also
trying to do things like have these
pregnancy centers where women could come
in and say you know I'm really
struggling with this I don't have the
the family to back me up and help me out
I don't have the finances so then there
are these pregnancy centers where they
try to help people so that they could
then give them up for adoption or figure
out other ways that they could maybe get
some donations Etc et cetera and then
what happens the Democrats Elizabeth
Warren we've shown you the video
they call this evil that this is evil
they're tricking them into having babies
and what could be worse for a woman than
having a baby God it's so crazy I just
got to tell you it's so crazy maybe this
is a little bit of me as a new father
but to have two young babies downstairs
you know in essence nine weeks and and
ten days about it's like that that
they're so obsessed
with murdering these children and lying
about it and scaring everybody it's just
vile and I've got a hell of a segue on
the word vile for you uh here's more
from MSNBC this is New York Times
Charles blow and uh yeah he's he's
basically a racist yeah can Democrats
fix the country or hold it together by
themselves no that's of course you can't
do that
um and the conversation has to be good
has to start with what we started with
in this conversation which is
what is your great fear about an America
that becomes more black brown Asian
what is your great fear about that
because it that is animating so much of
this uh that is animating a lot of the
racial violence around this it is
animating a lot of the voter suppression
that we exceed we it is animating a lot
of how we deal with education uh
politically deal with education it all
has its roots in this idea that this
white power and white culture is fragile
and under attack
the country as we knew it as they
created it the mythology they created
around it is under attack
and until we deal with the root of why
they are afraid of that so afraid that
they would violently defend it from
happening
I mean these people are just bananas
they live in an alternate universe you
know what's interesting what he tried to
do there it's a very clever thing that
he tried to do on they meaning the white
people they're afraid of America
becoming more black and brown and Asian
you know it's funny because Asian hate
crimes are through the roof right now
and you're not going to believe who
virtually all of the perpetrators of the
violence is yeah it happens to be black
men
I don't take any great pleasure in
telling you that but that is the truth
but they're trying to create this
intersectional Alliance that makes no
sense is Charles blow coming out against
Harvard we know that Harvard
discriminates against Asian people to
allow more black people in is he against
that or is he actually for equity which
discriminates against Asian people and
white people I know he's for that
version of it so everything they say is
complete nonsense no no one there it's
not to say there are no racists you get
it I'm not even going to bother with
that nonsense uh here's more from MSNBC
here's a guy who looks like a villain
from Batman there is right now an
anti-democracy side and a pro-democracy
side in American life it's very simple
it's not about party ID at this point it
is about whether you are for continued
and expanded liberal democracy or not it
is a dead Heat between democracy and
fascism and so I set out in the
persuaders to ask why I got tired of
despairing watching this show and all
the excellent coverage of this descent
towards Fascism and authoritarianism and
and why is this happening and why are we
relegated to despairing about it and I
got tired of my own Despair and decided
to spend the last couple years reporting
on people who are showing another way
particularly organizers working on the
ground in communities across this
country outside the Limelight activists
political leaders scientists as a cult
deprogrammer in the book because as you
have covered on this show we are there
with millions of our fellow citizens
remember when that guy robbed the Gotham
City Bank with Two-Face and Bane
remember that episode that was nuts
um okay yeah we're fascists and we're
authoritarians us the people who want
the state to stay open the people who
don't want to forcibly object inject
people you guys get it everything that
they say about us is what they are as uh
as my buddy Viva fry says it's
confession through projection it is just
rather extraordinary and what's sad
about this is that Democrats were not
always this way there was a same
Democrat Party and I do think after the
implosion and destruction of this rotten
woke Socialist Communist monster that we
have now that it's possible in I don't
know a couple years that maybe uh the
spirit of liberalism will rise again I
think that is possible
um but it ain't gonna happen anytime
soon and these the people that are
pushing these ideas they need to be
removed these ideas need to be removed
from from public discourse they can have
these ideas privately but these are
these are anti-American ideas and
they're the ones who love they love the
Confluence of corporate and political
power what did I just show you what's
happening in California right now they
are trying to criminalize dissent
related to covid and they're going to do
it in conjunction with big Tech someone
there's a word with an F related to that
oh right fascism the thing that he keeps
saying that we're trying to bring in but
again guys Democrats were not always
like this how about we go back about 50
years there was a guy named John F
Kennedy Jr and he was a Democrat and
what did he think about America and our
right to use power and how we should be
judicious about such things
that the United States is neither
omnipotent nor omniscient
only 6
6 of the world's population
and that we cannot impose our will upon
the other 94 percent of mankind
that we cannot write every wrong or
reverse each adversity and that
therefore there cannot be an American
solution to every world problem
there can't be an American solution to
every world problem that used to be the
position of the Democrats and it was
thought that the Republicans were the
one who ones who won a nation build and
impose our will and we're an imperialist
regime and all of these things and and
what of course comes with that also uh
that he he gets too further in that
speech is that we can't fix every
problem here meaning that the government
cannot fix every problem we certainly
can't fix every problem over there and
we can't fix every problem over here
that used to be a Democrat position that
was the that was basically the purpose
of having a sort of sane liberal
Democrat Party uh that party no longer
exists anymore and instead you have a
Batman cartoon characters who are
accusing everyone else of being fascists
while they usher in fascism themselves I
sometimes kind of admire it uh all right
stick around for a cold close we've got
some comments from the locals Community
Tony says I was watching the Austin
Peterson show this morning Austin was
talking to Judge Napolitano and Joe
judge Knapp mentioned Dave as a defender
of free speech oh well I I dig both
those guys to Austin Peterson who is a
great dude a full-throated Libertarian
real fun guy and judge Knapp who's just
fantastic so thank you for that uh free
he says Trudeau along with Newsom need
to get sucked into a black hole
how about now I'll be told I'm racist
for saying black hole EK says what's
interesting is that unvaccinated people
are generally healthier now than
vaccinated people well I would love to
do a study on that or or hear about a
study on that read a study on that I
mean it's interesting because again I
know plenty of people who are unvaxxed
who are perfectly healthy they're not
having any side effects from a thing
that they didn't take and that don't
regret it they're they're actually quite
proud I I really mean it I'm quite proud
of the fact that for those two years
that we all had unbelievable pressure
born to us right brought to our door
whether it was the government or fearing
you were going to lose your job or
whether it was family members or
whatever it might be
and if you stood your ground through
that and now you've been proven right we
deserve cookies we're gonna you know
what Daphne's been making the cookies
what kind of cookie you want
you want the chocolate chip what do you
want chocolate chip too all right we're
having chocolate chip cookies in honor
of not being vaccinated that's what's
happening here for the rest of the day
guys as always like And subscribe
whether you're watching on YouTube
rumble or on the Blaze and uh you can
join us for live chat and much more at
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview with Miami mayor he's a great
dude and I love this city and I love
this state mayor Francis Suarez is up
across platforms right now the full
thing is up with no ads on locals and I
leave you with the elderly man
pretending to be president being very
confused
the right that I pushed hard and it
finally got changed the married couples
in the privacy of their bedroom excuse
me the matter I'm thinking about the the
Dobb's decision imagine well I'll get to
that in a second